Oooh here we are!
Back at it again! :D
Holy shit (づ・∀・)づ oh my God
I am not BARRELS
I hate this...should we knock?
Yeah? Hello?
The fuck is this?
Hey they've got corn and everything! :O
Hello there mister man :D
Hey, you look good man
Oh! Jesus Christ you scared the shit out of me
Why is there a tricycle here? D:
Oh god it's getting dark man
It's getting well dark man
Aww fuck
You know shits about to go down... when the drums starts hitting
Oh god this is fucking creepy man
Wot was that
*SCARE PEWDIEPIE PLAYS ON THE CINEMA SCREEN AND THUNDERS*
Alright this is pretty good so far
What a nice town ｡◕ ‿ ◕｡
*PEWDS JUMPS OFF THE CHAIR LIKE A ROCKET*
OHMYGOD
Fuck fuck
FUCK INDEED
Oh thats cool man
This is so fucking cool
*CAMERA BOOPS*
SLAAAAAAMIN
Whoa what the fuck??
SLAAAM
Hey... no.. I hear you Ethan Bradberry
SLAAAAMIN
What the fuck are you doing ಠ_ಠ
You fucking asshole D:<
Why you gotta be so loud mannn
I ain't scared
*DOOR SLAMS*
Huh? Jävlar (fuck), fitta (cunt)
Oh
Corn, I love corn so much ಥ‿ಥ
Oh climb over. Oh thank god.
Awh FUCk
I am so fucked..
Fuck this...RUUNNAEGHWJE
OOOH OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Ooh my god
Im fine!
[Pewds]I'm fine...
I'M Fine...
Fine...
Where- where am I?
Excuse me
I burp when Im excited
Marzia doesnt appreciate it, I know but...
Whoooaa it's Lickitung again!
That fucking Pokemon
It'sgotMarzia (Wutface)
What the fuck, are those...
What the fuck is that?
Oh okay..no that's...great.
That's funny because I was actually heading this way, towards the exit. Yes.
Aw come on (╯°□°）╯
Alright, Im out
Poods out
Ah shit I ran out of batteries